mange déjà beaucoup de pâtisseries qui
sont faites par des machines et des
robots déjà toute la pâtisserie
industrielle elle est pas faite à la
main
[Musique]
alors ça sert à réaliser en fait des
pièces de structure on va appeler ça des
par exemple des fantartes de forme
totalement différentes de manière
automatisée donc ça permet d'éviter à la
fois l'outillage et ça aide les
boulangers pâtissiers qui parfois ont
des tensions au niveau du personnel
quand quelqu'un est absent c'est une
aide pour fluidifier la production
non l'idée vraiment c'est pas de faire
un gâteau en entier c'est en faire une
partie de telle façon à ce que les
pâtissiers les cuisiniers ils puissent
se concentrer sur les tâches de pochage
de remplissage l'agencement des textures
des couleurs la partie artistique en
fait de création d'un dessert qui est
objectivement le plus intéressant
votre boulanger est pâtissier à côté de
chez vous ou le restaurant il y a
beaucoup de choses qui sont faits avec
des machines ou malheureusement il y a
beaucoup de choses qui sont faits sur
des lignes industrielles et qui arrive
congelées dans les restaurants et dans
les boulangeries pâtisseries et où ils
deviennent un point de décongélation là
l'idée c'est vraiment qu'il puisse avec
l'imprimante 3D refaire 100% chez eux en
local
c'est pas possible avec la technologie
existante nous c'est une technologie
particulière qui est à base de poudre
comme vous le voyez en fait on sait pas
la farine des éléments liquides et on
vient mélanger les élans liquide dans la
farine directement pour créer le gâteau
donc c'est plutôt une technologie une
machine qui est destinée à des
professionnels elle est un peu grosse
pour rentrer dans une cuisine
souhaitez-moi bonne chance si ça va bien
vous êtes un jour on en fera une version
pour le grand public
[Musique]